it's Odell Beckham jr. we're playing
start fence cut I'm gonna be giving the
category I'm have to pick one to start
on the bench and one to cook I must
start you know I'm from the water so the
card at three and we started I'm a best
of blueprint cuz it was it's up there
and you know as much as I love get rich
or die trying' and what it did for me
during that time I'm have to cut it only
because we're in this game and what
about any given Sunday
you didn't even throw it in there I I
take Rudy out because I can't remember
Rudy at the moment Friday Night Lights I
cut Vince Remember the Titans because
classic and it was my favorite and any
given Sunday I have to start it al
pacino Jamie Foxx Willie Beamen Lawrence
Taylor was in it just was a hard movie
to me I mean I remember our Patino's
speech and I kind of you know I'm in the
locker room and I can hear that and I
can feel that and it was something that
was relatable and he was kind of talking
about one moment and one opportunity and
you know it's really like that I love
Serena but
I'm have to put it there it's tough to
go against Tom but he's really the goat
like he he really does that you know so
it but I can't start him over Tiger so
it's like I got to give him like eco
playing time or something and and and we
won't we won't cut Sarina or Bitzer and
we'll share the playing time between Tom
Brady and Tiger Woods
I'm Odell Beckham jr. and that was start
best cut